The results yield an expected value for
price given the characteristics of our diamond, and
the upper and lower bounds of a 95%
confidence level. Note, because this is a linear
model, predict is just multiplying each model coefficient
by each value in our data. It turns
out that this diamond is a touch pricier
than the expected value under the full model,
though it is by no means outside of the 95% confidence interval.
Blue now has by most accounts a better reputation than diamond SE.info
however. And reputation is worth a lot in a business that relies
on easy to forge certificates in which the non-expert can be easily fooled.
So, while this model might give you a sense of whether your diamond is a ripoff
against diamondSE.info diamonds, it's not clear that diamondSE.info
should be regarded as the universal source of truth
over whether the price of a diamond is
reasonable. Nonetheless, to have the expected price and diamondassay.info
with a 95% interval, is a lot more
information than we had about the price we should
be willing to pay for a diamond before we started this exercise.